[Music]
yeah that's that's good that's good
audience good job you really K oh you
turn it off right away though don't you
drain the pan show them zero you went
right to
zero every day we do this the show and
the card says uh thank you welcome to
the pet home I'm tired of this card give
me this card James you read this
card you can come
up hello J do it to the camera thank you
go thank you hello everybody very
natural K home show
[Music]
yeah thank you James you can keep it you
keep
that my favorite thing about that whole
thing was how ready he was most people
would be like me he was like yeah I got
this yeah came up you were gonna host
the whole show if I was just like take
it
James uh so tonight I wanted to talk
about food trucks any we talk about food
trucks for a little bit food
trucks yeah
see people get all people get all
excited you love food trucks I love food
trucks we all love food trucks but we
shouldn't listen it's food on a truck
that's the end of the description why do
we all lose are over food on a
truck it's not that great the whole
concept just seems like something I
would have come up with as a toddler you
know what I mean like hey hey little py
what do you want to eat I'm like
petti oh how do you want that on a
twuck oh so the truck can come to us no
so we have to go looking for it in Kia
town I get it I get it they seem fun
they seem like a good time they're like
ice cream trucks but for adults the
problem is they don't serve ice cream
it's like someone saw them and was like
oh an ice cream truck you know what the
fun part of that is the
truck let's bring that into other
mediums let's get rid of that pesky
dessert everyone loves and instead we'll
sell Persian tacos in a pita for1
1350 I like that sounds good I'm not
done and they're going to have to wait
outside on the sidewalk for 45 minutes
in a dangerous neighborhood cuz I can't
find the
cilantro I'm just James I'm saying
that's what it is really you wait online
you're breathing carbon monoxide and for
what a restaurant with no choices and
nowhere to sit it's just here's your
meatball you're on your
own at least with ice cream trucks
selling it out of a truck kind of makes
sense cuz in an ice cream truck all you
need is a freezer but I don't really
trust lobster rolls to a repurposed
ambulance you know what I
mean you couldn't keep my grandma alive
let alone mayonnaise
okay okay that is that is
terrible that
is couldn't keep Grandma alive
okay let alone manise we're having do it
twice if it works do it
twice but i' I've given a lot of thought
and I think I figured out why people
love food trucks it's because they're
elusive they're like leprechauns at self
faaf you know what I mean there's a
magical feeling when you finally spot
one I get it it's like if you went to
the mall and you went to the food court
one day and Panda Express just wasn't
there if it just vanished and it's your
favorite and you're like
what it's usually next to
Sparrow it's always it's always been
next to Sparrow where's Pandy press
where's I really thought Pand press
would do
better where's Pand Express both times C
minus my point is is even if you're not
that crazy about Pandy press if it
wasn't there and then one day you just
saw a Panda Express idling on 25th
Street you'd be like there it
is oh my
God it's so
exciting seeing a food truck even if you
only kind of like it it's like seeing an
ex-girlfriend you haven't seen in years
and she Whispers that she's only in town
for one night it's a great
idea but then after you hang out for a
couple hours you're like all right I
remember why we stopped doing this you
give me
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
diarrhea